ضعفت فتاه بلغاريا حجم شفتيها بنحو اربعه
اضعاف عن حجمهم الطبيعي بعدما خضعت لعمليه
التجميل الثانيه والثلاثين لتصبح صاحبه
اكبر شفتين في العالم وافقت الفتاه حتى
الان حوالي ثمانيه الاف جنيه استرليني في
العيادات التجميليه لحقن وتضخيم شفتها
وعلى الرغم من ان لديها اكبر الشفاه
بالعالم الا انها لا تشعر بالرضا عنهما
وانها ستستمر في حقنهما حتى تشعر بالرضا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتشر مقطع فيديو لموقف محرج لحظه سقوتيده
اندونيسيا الاولى اريانا جوكر اثناء
نزولها من الطائره برفقه زوجها لحضور قمه
مجموعه العشرين في جزيره باله
[موسيقى]
احدثت الفنانه هند عاكف حاله من الجبل على
سجاده الحمراء بمهرجان القاهره سينمائيه
الدولي بعدما حاول المنظمون منعها من
الدخول بسبب ارتدائها فستانا مخالفا
للتعليمات وعليه صور لفنانين قدامى ولكنها
تمكنت من الدخول بعد خلاف مع الامن
وارتفاع صوتها بشكل كبير
ريماس
توفي المخرج والممثل الاردني اشرف طلفاح
يوم الاثنين الماضي بعد وجوده في قسم
العنايه المركزه باحد المستشفيات المصريه
وذلك وسطر جدلا كبير حول ظروفي هذه الوفاء
انباء تحدثت عن تعرضه لاعتداء من قبل
مجهولين في القاهره لكن الخارجيه الاردنيه
عاده واكدت انه لم يثبت دخوله اي شخص الى
شقه الفنان الراحل مشيره الى عدن وجود اي
شبهه جنائيه
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء